holy de pret a cool pear you know
that is an electoral for united
russia
the animal has often been used de
symbolized de rowling party en hesp in
high het hier to entertain supporters
dat ludmilla steven koah but the united
was a veteran was inner member  or the
moscow duma
and regional parliament st it was
founded in ninety-nine the tree is not
running fore party of the bell the
season independent candidate and i'm
running arms my ball see this
party hmmm play suit I don't give in to us
loose photos  libot
already have a bit on her channel we him
danny problem
he keeps the time and money right across
there just think we was
knows thinks for the party which was
founded zon off of vladimir putin became
president in ninety-nine thymine
claps and level patient  tot 20% beastdier
of drie time and tagged with increased
and more of that led to a nationwide
protest
joling last years regional election
united was a last voor kan van
provisions
enne  let's say the parties barry take it
be calm and liabilities
have checked a pedrali for you your
bed to the single party flac or balor
can seen
we know mr vr4 between the hope
people in morocco and one or not
reviews the partners take what nv it  show
how the plight it was falling
the usually loki was collections he
leaves the world wide attention to
be up gerty opposition knew the
front of running government official
site of app minnes traitor's mistakes the
decision led two weeks of protest
knew the tempo texels wind  who trains and
one lead in opposition knew the logo
sucks
goin' on a hunger strike is god
light shows there in moscou' their position
is cho to cost hassle-free paula
problem she still did this family for one
and printers and actions candidates
winner the mere at the  was fine to
date slipped a bit of political wind
the chairman of the moscow just
round here and paint rail she said
disqualification en of the oppos  ition can be
the zipper let you relax with
and cozy election process spear the rubrum
by don bosco totally
mikro-electro processes more exciting
war wage knew this could be watched
there according to judge me anyway a
green left to it certainly price but
at a lot if  I have jokes doctor
through already kill masco dumas is
shows is an influential body the
election saw can sit it cake for
national actions to the is of well we
would power party and parliament with
could be more difficult for president
putin to stay in power bi  country is
last weekend in twenty twenty four
step phase al jazeera
moscow